m
dijonnais deux professeurs du lycée
rabemananjara séjourne actuellement à la
réunion
ils sont les heureux lauréats de la
compétition nationale de français qui
s'est déroulé à madagascar
cette opération a permis à plus de 500
lycéens de mesurer le raison sur scène
leur jeu d'acteur en produisent en
spectacle théâtral original d'une durée
de 20 minutes entièrement en langue
française alors pendant ces dix jours
ils vont découvrir effectivement la
réunion parce que pour la plupart ils ne
connaissent pas pour la plupart
d'ailleurs ils n'ont jamais quitté l'île
de madagascar et il découvre la fois le
le vivre à la réunionnaise
ils vont découvrir également les
établissements du département ils vont
visiter les musées ils vont se déplacer
sur des lieux historiques également ils
vont visiter musée de villèle le lazaret
plein d'éléments qui font le parcours
historique qui nous est commun entre
madagascar et la ring une équipe
victorieuse pour qui ce voyage
représente une véritable chance et une
belle occasion de s'enrichir et de
découvrir une nouvelle culture
ça représente une expérience énorme
parce que c'est comme une vie qui
commence
voir la réunion une une si belle ville
s'est très c'est phénoménal
c'est très phénoménal je m'attends à ce
que ce soit très très formelle et que ça
me donne beaucoup davantage d
informations sur l'île de la réunion et
que ça me donne aussi beaucoup de
plaisir parce que déjà ce sont les
vacances et les vacances on s'amuse
gérant ce voyage les jeunes sont
accompagnés par leur professeur de
français et par la présidente de la pf à
ces dernières se sont beaucoup investis
pour la réussite de leurs jeunes talents
et démontre la place importante occupée
par la francophonie à madagascar
moi je trouve qu'il est très important
d'apprendre le français aux jeunes
malgaches pourquoi tout simplement parce
que le français pour moi il est une
langue de culture nous avons toujours
considéré la langue française comme
notre patrimoine culturel et piles
il faut voir aussi dans le monde c'est
une langue désocialisation les a débuté
leur séjour par la visite du musée du
sel à saint leu c'est sous un temps
ensoleillé qu'ils ont pu découvrir ce
site exceptionnel le seul où l'on
fabrique du sel à la réunion un groupe
de jeunes réunionnais effectué eux aussi
la visite même instant une véritable
fusion s'est alors créé entre les deux
groupes
une visite qui s'est transformé en un
moment de partage et de convivialité
une rencontre entre deux il pas si
différente
la part en suisse et l'apparence partage
des cultures des beaux moments et ils
sont gentils aussi une pâle boncourt se
présente
ben c'était un moment magique parce que
nous même je pense que les jeunes avec
moi on n'est jamais parti à madame donc
c'était une occasion pour nous d'être
d'être à madame et à la réunion donc
c'était un moment de partage et il n'y a
pas tous les jeunes qui ont eu cette
chance là donc voilà nos ancêtres sans
de mada donc on est fiers et voilà vive
madagascar la compétition nationale de
france est un événement qui porte en lui
les valeurs qui font de la francophonie
un moyen de création favorisant la
réflexion et le partage à travers les
échanges d'expériences
la nuit
le match